[音楽]
re 品
goo
[音楽]
voodoo
みなさんこんにちはえっと
ここはですねあの宮城県の川崎町
基さんって言う
ところです
ここは今日はね僕の単語からいい
僕はですね佐藤まさずみと申しまし
ヤゴは今ここ散ったっていう屋号であのーかをやらさ
5年前にここに移住していけ
それからずっと農業をやらせてもらってるんですけど
倒木は今自然栽培という農法に取り組まれています
レザーバイっていうんです
あの一般的にこれこれこうだんって言われるー
の中でちょっと難しいんですけれども一般的に言うと
農薬や肥料も何にも使わないね
の野菜やお米まあ果樹とかそういうものを育てるっていう方で
みなさんがよくご存じのオーガニック
って一般的に言われるものとはまた少し違っているんですね
一般的なそのオーガニックっていうのはやっぱりその動物性の肥料とか
もちろん家で作った植物性の移動とかいうこと
畑や田んぼに入れてその医療ね
もちろん微生物た
すっかり後を追おう
妻たちに日々となって野菜を育てていっぱい収穫をとっ
それで打ってこういったおっ
長野方なんですけども司令栽培でちょっと違って
費用を使わないんですよ
じゃあ皆さんよくやっぱり火を使わないで野菜できるのかっていう
思われる方もいると思うので少しそれで話しさせていただこうかなと
その自然栽培に取り組んで
の中で僕が気づいたことを皆さんとシェアさせていただけたらなぁと思って
ここで話させてもらっています
僕はまだ全然5年目なのねー
こうやればできるとかああやればできるっていう脳幹は
全くもってありませんん
は一つあるとすれば
なんでもいいからやってみようと
一度やってみないと
どうなるかがわからないかなぁ
やってみないと始まらないよねっていう
そのやってみるって言う
気持ちだけは
まあ
と思っています
すごい大事だなと思ってやってみないとは考えてる
例えばまあ
大げさな話えっ沖縄県で
あのこれこれこうやってこうやったら育ったよしてやり方をここに持ってきてほしい
って育たないん
もしくは9川崎町の隣は秋保町っていうところなんですけど
秋保町でやっているやり方と川崎町でやっているやり方その
同じくやったらできるのかってまた違う
隣の田んぼ道師の違う
環境が全然違うんですよ
僕が当てる自然栽培で大事にしているのはその環境を整えるということをやっているん
です
例えばトマトだったら乾燥しているものが好きだし
あもちろん皆さんの知ってる単語なんかも
陸稲っていう陸で育つものもあるけれど基本的に水でんですよね
水を張って水がある環境で
育てられるそういう環境
があるのね
その環境をつくってくるんですか
その環境を作るにあたって僕がすごい大事です
じゃあ昨日まで
僕がイメージしているのは
例えば
この今みなさんが見ている景色
人間がいなくなったとして例えばですね人間がいなくなったとして10年
100年
果たしてここはどうなっているかなん
話します
多分森に帰っていると思います
田舎に暮らし始めて今5年目まだ5人なんですけど
1年の大半日下にしてません
ほっとくとどんどんどんどん雑草って僕らが読んでる雑草が入ってきて
反物畑も道路もう
家ですなぁ
草に覆われるんですよ
難燃化するツール植物に覆われちゃってもう見えなくなっ
その後は被害
まーた気なんかがあったらどんどん入ってきます
僕らはそれを
では一生懸命くさんあっ
まあホット大きいブルドーザーでカーッとを整地しちゃったりして
その
雑草と書が入ってくれエネルギー戦っている
今ここにある景色はもうすべてはその後李に帰ろうとするエネルギーが
で満ちてるんですよここ
残忍をしなければかつてにそれもどって食ってエネルギーがここ
があるんですね
その
エネルギーが
おお米や野菜に伝えてあげたいっ
お米や野菜にそのエネルギーが伝わるようなそういう環境を作ってあげたいな
ん
その環境を作ることさえできれば確かに農薬無肥料もいらずに使わずにずっと
永続的に
ここで農業ができていくんだろうなぁという漠然としたイメージがあります
やっぱり30年40年やられている方の田んぼや畑を見させていただいたこともあるん
ですけれども
やっぱり肥料がなくても
その土地で
やり続け
おもしろ
やり始めた時よりもよくなっ
言われています
話を聞きます
僕もやってみたいん
その中ですごい大事にしていることがあるんですけど
やっぱり
今の世の中のスピードで2
例えば
何だろう例えば野菜がね僕らが手をピッ
言っているような状態になっちゃうんだ
虫がいっぱい発生したとっ
あんな雑草やこんな雑草が生えてきたぞとか
あんだか知らないけど水がすごい長いフォンできたとか
混ぜて行っちゃった
いろんなことが起こるんです
台風も来るする
を理由に来る旬
多摩層向けに
頭だけ大きな話に戻すとあっておきだこれをやらなきゃいけない
オーガニックでも農薬はれます
そういうオーガニックの農薬を使ってそれをなおすっ
もしくは殺す
付与する前に
一旦立ち止まってい
それを観察してほしいなって思うんです
みんなに見せたかったオクラの写真があるんですけれども今年で写真撮るの忘れちゃっ
て&誰にも見せられなかったんですけど
僕のオクラがですね今年
もう南部は何百本も植えているんですけれどもある
地域がん
なんだん
あぶら虫だらけでもうしなしなしなくなっちゃったんですよ
ああこれはまずいと
ちょっと焦る気持ちもあったけどでもやっぱりしてい
まあ何回かの経験ね
もしその子がだめでも他の子があっ
で他もこう生かすためにこの子に虫がつくっていう現象も誇るんですね
案の定オクラはすぐ復活してい
今年もおいしいオクラを食べることができたんです
ついこのスピードで生きていると現在社会のこのスピードで生きていると何かがあっ
たらすぐ対処対処体臭
そういう風になっていくんですけれども
一歩立ち止まって観察してみることができればそこに意味があるって事日がつけるん
ですよね
全部君がある
その意味に気がつけさえすればその子たちと一緒に
その減少とともに共存することができるんです
もちろん僕もそれで生計を立てたり
食べるものを得たりしてるので
ああしたいこうしたいこうだったらいい
いろんな思いが思っちゃうつはあるんですよね
その想いすらもちょっと置いといて a
一度観察してみるん
あるがまんまのその現象をただ見てブルー
それについて考えてい
思った以上に
うまくいくつ
自然現象雨とか対応
串とか
全部が全部成り立ってて
ミカサンって言った
それはすごくうまくいく
これからだから農業だけじゃなくてもう
いろいろ仕事をしていく中でやっぱり一度観察してみるその物事の本質は何なのかって
考えてみる
わからなくても気がつけなくても
観察しようと心がけルカから掛けないかで大きく世界は変わってくると思う
線栽培ってすごくあの
そういうこととの葛藤ですやっぱり終了が減ったりとか
デイたりとかもうすごい波があるのねー
なかなか
続けていけるとかな寄付は僕にもあるんですけれども
そういうビジョンを持った仲間達っていうのもやっぱり増えてきてるのねー
あのぜひ皆さんもですねああ
僕の畑に単語にお遊びに来て一緒に行こう
世界を感じてねこれからどうやって生きていこうかな
どうゆう
普通にいって言ったら僕らは持続可能ね幸せに生きていけるんだろうなぁということを
まともに考えながらやっていけたらいいなと思ってます
本当に短い時間でしたが今日はこんな感じでー
宜しくお願いいたしますありがとうございます
ちなみにですね今ここの田んぼは稲刈りをして長谷川系ですけど天日干しをしている
状態なんですけれどもこの状態で今2週間だった
みんなねー
泥まみれになりながら
視界に入らないところあってで買った子どもたちも
も泥まみれになってやったところで
あと1週間ほどでこれをざっと2ってあああの機械にかけて
ana モンド外すんですよ
そこから今度はそのもに柄を飛ばして
精米して
発生場所は各国は現場に食べるん
あですけどまぁもみ殻を外してや桃米の完成品
ねその
タネからまた来編金を開いてまた来年ここがスタートするっていう
そういう繰り返し
楽しいですね
楽しいです
何だろう
自分が
そのタネを取ったりすることによって自分がそう
命の循環の中に身を置くことがやっと出来たなぁ
あこれは1年通してい
いや2年3年通して
自分で金を取っ
その土地と向き合っていう
そうだていっ
僕も育てられ
収穫してまた来年そのためのツナ入り上
命の循環のサイクルの名前
7ん
色が変わって見えると思う
はいっ
ています